I'm empty but I found a way to make it
feel this bottomless got the chills
Golden Globe winner Michael C Hall may
be best known for playing a vigilantes
serial killer induction look at that
stare now he's back in the new Netflix
original dramas safe created by New York
Times bestselling author that's Harlan
Coben safe follows surgeon Tom Delaney a
grief-stricken Widow trying to find
answers when his teenage daughter goes
missing it seems they've bought train
tickets Chris's vest posed at the
station I checked that times they'd
written down with the timetable they go
south into the city
she bought a fake ID of a guy online why
well you need ID for drinking clubbing
maybe she's just a runaway gone off so
she can why would she do that
Harlan Coben is also an executive
producer of safe there's nothing safe
about it he's here with Michael there's
nothing safe about this first guys
Michael welcome welcome thank you I was
thrown a little bit by the English
accent but before we get started you
guys should know in the green room
Harlan said Gale I'm just here for the
eye candy today I'm just here to be the
good-looking guy said bald is in but
when I first started watching it I heard
the English accent my dog threw me
because I wasn't expecting that right so
you read the script and you thought what
I want to play him because well the fact
that he was an Englishman was a part of
the appeal part of the unique challenge
but I think more importantly it was the
quality of the script the quality of the
dialogue that Danny Brocklehurst had
written and the quality of the story
itself that Harlan had constructed I
think there were three moments when I
read the first script that my jaw drop
that was a good sign yeah yeah
it also yeah it was a fusion of so many
things
a thriller family drama and he's a
regular
there was nothing regular about you and
Six Feet Under yeah and Dexter yeah it
was nice it was nice to play someone to
whom crazy things are happening
I mean Harlan you're such a successful
author and this is your first is that
right right but now Netflix right this
first series for Netflix it's so
exciting it's just a new way of telling
stories for me I mean it's eight
episodes it's like a novel put right on
the screen I mean I want you to binge it
the way you bend your novel I want you
to think I'm just gonna watch one
episode just one click it to yes
challenging yeah it's a different skill
set right yeah well first of all we have
the great shocking ending I can't wait
right when they come I are kind of
having fun with you you're hyping it up
Carla deliver I promise here I'm telling
you no one can they're not gonna guess
it they're gonna be surprised they're
not gonna guess I'm not gonna get the
last episode everybody takes a nap yeah
but is each episode like a chapter you
know is that basically that and it was
that easy exactly and we want to end it
I mean that was the thing like when I
both wanted to do we didn't want to have
one of these things where like The
Sopranos ending well you don't want to
have it where you have to wait for
season two to get the answers if you
invest the time to watch eight episodes
we felt it was important you got all the
answers okay well we're like The
Sopranos where they ended it and then it
was open to interpretation are you
saying there's anything there's no open
it's not open to it no I mean I guess
there's perhaps some ambiguity in terms
of where people go from there yeah being
the ending but no all the important
questions that are posed or asking
Michael how do you get into a character
like this as you mentioned it's very
different than the ones before there's
also an English accent are you going
around the household for weeks in well I
was I was I was doing a job in London on
stage when I got the job and so I was
able to just wander the streets of
London muttering to myself for a few
months before I started the job I mean
muttering to myself at an English accent
right but the accident was certainly a
big part of the preparation I think it
was such an immersive experience we shot
this in Manchester with an English crew
and was living there and so so much of
the sort of imaginative stuff was taken
care of because I was in a genuinely
foreign place and yeah that did a lot of
the work for me
and for people who just need to give us
a quick tease of who the characters are
well the the character I play Tom
Delaney is a pediatric surgeon Army
veteran he is six months from being
widowed and as a newly single father of
two girls 116-112 and he's finding
himself a little out of his depth in
terms of his ability to be a good father
and have any sense of what's going on
with him and I guess one important thing
he reveals to his friend at the
beginning of the first episode is that
he's downloaded this software that
allows him to track her kids her
messages on her phone which becomes a
real important story but it also opens
up about parenting teenagers too yeah
yeah how close do you watch them on the
internet and boy does it explode in his
face when he does and just revealing it
to everyone in town has a secret it's a
gated community and for families and
when the teenage party goes wrong a lot
of Secrets are going to comport out it's
a lot of fun nothing likes secrets and a
missing teenager to make a series of
teenagers a little nervous see Hall and
Harlan Coben thank you so much for being
welcome carlisle it's my middle name
michael carla hall very nice name I
think so too safe against dreaming
tomorrow on Netflix